well anything that indicates that there
are two Sexes is now offensive because
we're meant to be entirely focused on
people who deny that fact and who also
aren't happy with their own sex so I
distinguish those two groups there are
trans people who aren't happy being the
sex that they are and some of them are
quite realistic about that they know
what their sex is they know it makes
them unhappy they're perfectly easy and
nice to talk to and then there's other
ones who want the whole world broken to
fit them back into the sex category that
they're not
and then there's a much larger penumbra
of people who think of themselves as
allies for whom it's extremely important
to deny the fact that there are two
Sexes and so those are the people who
are destroying women's rights destroying
children's education are destroying gay
people's rights because you can't have
sexual orientation without sex they're
willing to break absolutely everything
in order that some men can count as
women and some women can count as men